[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de fútbol de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Asia tiene otro representante en octavos
la selección de Corea del Sur venció a
Portugal y se clasificó segundo en el
grupo H el resultado dejó fuera de la
segunda fase a Uruguay selección que
superó a gana pero no le alcanzó para
alcanzar los octavos
Camerún le quitó el invicto a Brasil al
derrotarlo Un gol por Cero en el último
partido de la fase de grupos
Lamentablemente para los leones
Indomables el resultado No Fue
suficiente para avanzar de ronda ya que
Suiza ganó su vuelo frente a Serbia
tenemos análisis
[Música]
están definidos los octavos de final la
fiesta de eliminación directa comenzará
este sábado con los partidos entre
Países Bajos y Estados Unidos y
Argentina enfrentando a Australia
analizamos la previa del compromiso
y para anualizar todo el acontecer de
cada jornada Contamos con la presencia
de Octavio sacio periodista de la
emisora Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido
Octavio Hola Luis un gusto saludarte
como siempre y También aprovecho para
darle la bienvenida a nuestra enviada
especial en Qatar comenzamos por Natalia
Ruiz Saludos Natalia
más adelante estaremos conversando con
ellos con Natalia y con juana desde
Qatar Pero de esta manera comenzamos
entonces hablando de Corea del Sur
porque es una selección que regresa unos
octavos de final instancia a la que no
llegaba desde la Copa del Mundo de
Sudáfrica en el año 2010 cuando avanzó
como segunda en su grupo que fue
liderado al final por Argentina en Qatar
2022 Corea del Sur superó en el último
partido a la selección de Portugal con
marcador de dos goles por uno un
encuentro que tiene un antecedente
dentro de copas del mundo ya que si
evaluamos lo que fue el torneo del año
2002 donde los coreanos fueron locales
junto a Japón Allí se enfrentó contra
Portugal y consiguió un importante
resultado Octavio quisiera hablar
contigo lo referente a esta selección de
Portugal una selección de Fernando
Santos que quizás ya sabiendo que estaba
no se forzó al máximo en este partido
frente a la selección de Corea Silvia
hay hay momentos y y transiciones en
esta Copa del Mundo sobre todo Yo creo
que por el por el tiempo en el que se
juega por la forma en Cómo llegaron las
elecciones y los países con el cansancio
acumulado que ha significado jugar en
esta etapa del año y por todo lo que
ocurrió antes porque evidentemente es un
mundial atípico que los entrenadores han
tomado ciertas decisiones no es
casualidad que por primera vez en la
historia de los mundiales no haya ningún
equipo que haya ganado los tres partidos
en la fase de grupos y Y eso tiene que
ver también con el hecho de dosificar lo
hizo didier de champs con Francia
sabiendo que sólo un un desastre lo iba
a sacar del primer lugar lo hace Brasil
lo hace Portugal y y digamos yo más allá
del resultado que termina siendo una una
derrota una victoria en favor de Corea
del Sur que a Corea del Sur le significa
el hecho de de clasificarse yo creo que
los portugueses en el fondo prefieren
descansar un poco y evitar esas fatiga
que evidentemente haber ganado los hay
partidos que matemáticamente no se lo
hubiese significado ningún cambio así
que me parece inteligente en cierto modo
incluso que los entrenadores puedan
dosificar un poco a sus jugadores
pensando evidentemente que a partir del
día de mañana comienza la verdadera copa
del mundo para muchos pero Octavio
quisiera también hablar un poco de esta
selección de Corea regresa a unos
octavos de final y podríamos hablar que
es un equipo que ha ido de menos a más a
lo largo de este torneo la verdad es que
me me gusta mucho lo que está pasando
con los equipos asiáticos sobre todo con
Japón y con Corea del Sur me hizo
recordar el mundial de de Corea y Japón
2002 que evidentemente estuvo lleno de
mucha polémica pero que Corea del Sur
tenía un equipo muy entretenido que
marcó evidentemente un antes y un
después que quedó cuarto lugar en
aquella en aquella competencia
evidentemente es como tú dices Luis este
equipo ha ido creciendo ha ido mejorando
a pesar de que en el medio tuvo ese
accidente que no pudo conseguir los
puntos en su partido frente frente a
gana pero jugó muy bien frente a Uruguay
y hoy hizo lo que tenía que hacer a
Corea del Sur le importaba pocos y
Portugal le ponía suplentes o no Corea
del Sur tenía que ganar el partido y la
jerarquía de son que demuestra Por qué
juega en la mejor liga del mundo terminó
dando Esa diferencia porque el pase de
son para el 2 a 1 y la victoria final
termina siendo pase de jugador de su de
su jerarquía de su trayectoria entonces
me parece que más allá de lo que pase Y
si Corea queda o no queda entre los ocho
mejores ha sido muy bueno lo de Corea y
lo de Japón y merecen evidentemente
estar en esta fase de la Copa Muchas
gracias Octavio pero vamos a aprovechar
para saludar a Juana pupiales nuestro
enviado especial en
Qatar y quien estuvo en este compromiso
entre Portugal y Corea del Sur Saludos
Juana desde acá desde Bogotá buenas
noches para usted allá en
Qatar Juan quisiera hablar un poco de
las sensaciones que dejó en el estadio
esta victoria de Corea del Sur frente a
Portugal en la jornada
de una sensación de que se hace justicia
con una selección que yo me he cansado
de decir aquí en este programa que juega
bien al fútbol y el fútbol estaba siendo
muy cruel con Corea del Sur Porque casi
que se queda por fuera de los octavos de
final hoy consiguió seguir fiel a su
Estilo dominar bien la pelota jugar con
un fútbol ofensivo y agradable y hoy
obtuvieron su premio y de una manera muy
bonita diría yo remontando en una
selección de Portugal Que obviamente
saltó al campo lleno de suplentes pero
finalmente una victoria contra una
selección europea contra una selección
como la de Portugal que es una aspirante
al título Corea del Sur que hoy tuvo O
aún
inspiradom que es el reflejo de lo que
fue este partido de Corea del Sur
Houston El capital y la estrella de este
equipo quería su gol quería conseguir
hoy su gol pero estaba muy frustrado
llegaba y llegaba no tomaba las mejores
decisiones en los últimos tres cuartos
del campo pero tomó la mejor decisión en
la jugada clave del partido córner a
favor de Portugal despeje la pelota que
la toman una carrera de 50 metros que se
pega cara la defensa portuguesa él solo
pero en ese momento es cuando tiene la
pausa la tranquilidad y asiste ajecham
asiste ají changua para que este jugador
que venía desde el banquillo marcara el
dos a uno definitivo luego vimos como
human cuando Se confirmó el pase a
octavos de final para Corea del Sur
después de esa victoria de dos a cero de
Uruguay Cómo se quitó la máscara la tiró
al suero y empezó a llorar de rabia eso
es lo que refleja este equipo ese equipo
que se mantuvo ese equipo surcoreano que
se mantuvo fiel a su estilo y que obtuvo
su premio que el fútbol de alguna manera
premia a Corea del Sur con esta
clasificación a octavos de final le
falta eso sí todavía el gol a Houston va
a tenerlo muy difícil contra Brasil pero
por qué no seguir soñando con esta
selección asiática que como decimos sabe
jugar muy bien al fútbol y viene con un
proceso muy interesante
ahora Juan lo largo del partido también
vimos al entrenador Fernando Santos de
Portugal retirar de la cancha a su mejor
jugador o a quizás uno de los emblemas
de esta selección lusitana como lo es
Cristiano Ronaldo salió al minuto 65 y
salió muy molesto del grabado esta
decisión han podido comprobar si se
debió al mal partido que estaba teniendo
Ronaldo en esta jornada o se debió más
bien pensando ya en la segunda fase del
torneo
Creo yo que Fernando Santos lo hace
sobre todo pensando en los octavos de
final en darle descanso jugador que ya
no tiene el físico que tenía antes
obviamente Cristiano Ronaldo eso no le
gustó ha marcado solamente solamente
entre comillas un gol en este mundial
ese penal tiene el partido inaugural y
el obviamente quiere seguir haciendo
historia en estos mundial es el único
hombre que ha marcado en cinco mundiales
en la historia de este campeonato desde
que salió Cristiano Ronaldo y desde el
banquillo también puso una muy mala cara
así que evidenciando que no le gustó el
cambio pero al final Portugal pasó a la
siguiente instancia como primera del
grupo Así que no tiene nada de que
reprocharse los portugueses y era lo que
se esperaba Dentro de este grupo pero
mientras Portugal se batía Duelo contra
Corea del Sur en el estadio
las elecciones de Uruguay y gana hacían
lo propio en un partido que estaba
marcado por el morbo por la sensación de
revancha luego de lo ocurrido En los
cuartos de final de Sudáfrica 2010 pero
ocurrió ese año su ley montaria abrió la
cuenta para el conjunto de ghana en el
agregado de la primera parte y Diego
forlán empató a los 54 minutos ese
partido así Se cerraron los 90 minutos
en el alargue se produjo lo impensable
Luis Suárez evitó un gol con la mano y
esto provocó un tiro penal que fue
fallado por Ian azamoa y que obligó a la
tanda de penales para decidir al ganador
allí el gol alopaneca de Sebastián Abreu
picando la pelota le dio el triunfo a
Uruguay y el pase a la siguiente ronda
pero aprovechamos para saludar a Natalia
Ruiz Natalia escuchando este relato Cómo
se vivió ese partido ahora en Qatar
muy buenas noches pues efectivamente
como usted viene lo contó y bien lo dijo
pues tenía todo ese toda esa sensación
de revancha y finalmente no se les dio a
los de gana que desperdiciaron la
oportunidad encima de eso un penalti un
poco como si la historia les pusiera ahí
la oportunidad en bandeja de plata y fue
Andrea Yu quien De hecho estaba en ese
partido en el 2010 quien pudo cobrar ese
penalti en el minuto 20 después de esa
falta de rochet sobre kundo y
desaprovechó la oportunidad porque creo
que de todo lo que hemos visto en este
mundial es Quizás El peor cobro de tiro
de tiro penal que se haya podido ver le
pegó muy mal rochet no tuvo problemas
para atajar esa pelota y pues así
desperdició esta gran oportunidad y
luego pues ya Uruguay se creció y luego
llegaron ya el llegó el doblete de
ascarradeta que daba El Triunfo y dio el
triunfo a Uruguay a la espera de lo que
pasara en ese otro loco partido de Corea
de el azul y ya en los últimos minutos
en donde ya Uruguay se da cuenta que no
le alcanza que le faltó un gol en todo
caso para poder pasar a la siguiente
ronda un partido Pues con muchísimas
emociones un estadio entre ganeses por
un lado los uruguayos por el otro
algunas pancartas que decían la Celeste
nunca muere y bueno Esperemos que la
Celeste nunca muera Vimos a Diego forlán
de hecho salir de este estadio con una
cara un poco Bueno pues acontecida
obviamente Así que fueron como muchas
emociones las lágrimas de Suárez eh en
el banquillo justamente cuando acababa
de darse cuenta pues que en Corea del
Sur acababa de de ganar el partido ante
Portugal así que pues bueno como pasar
de la gloria a la total desilusión en
tan solo unos minutos eso fue lo que
vivimos en ese partido allí en el llano
imágenes impactantes la de Luis Suárez
llorando en el banco al percatarse que
había notado el segundo gol Corea del
Sur pero Octavio hablemos un poco Cómo
analizar esta de esta salida temprana de
Uruguay dentro del torneo si tomamos en
cuenta que era una selección que por el
proceso que venía viviendo con Diego
Alonso se esperaba que podía estar en
instancias decisivas Dentro de este
torneo en Qatar este partido como decía
Natalia es para un documental
perfectamente estaban en la tribuna
Diego forlán y El loco Abreu dos de los
protagonistas de aquel partido frente a
gana en el mundial de de Sudáfrica
estaba el jugador que guerra ayuw el que
era el penal y hace que gana se
convierta en el único país en la
historia en fallar dos penales frente al
mismo rival es decir había mucho
condimento alrededor de eso pero bueno
Luego evidentemente Uruguay le pasa
factura el hecho de no poder concretar
las posibilidades de Gol que tuvo no
solo en este partido sino a lo largo de
toda la copa del mundo es cierto que
luego de la de la derrota o de digamos
del partido que si bien es cierto lo
gana pero lo que significa una derrota
Diego Alonso dice que se quedan afuera
por aquel segundo penal que que recibe a
Portugal por aquel Portugal para el 2 a
0 pero la autocrítica tiene que pasar
porque un equipo que tenga a Suárez a
cavani a Darwin Núñez tiene que marcar
más goles de los que marcó lo otro es
que nos mostró Diego Alonso que sí podía
jugar Georgia de rascadita como titular
en este equipo y que lamentablemente Fue
muy poco tiempo el que jugó el jugador
de flamengo valga la redundancia como
para demostrar su capacidad marcó los
dos goles de hoy es muy llamativo la
forma Luis cómo termina eliminado
Uruguay con Suárez en el banco y con de
rascadete en el banco sabiendo que
tenían que marcar una buena cantidad de
goles para no depender del resultado de
Corea del Sur y aún así terminan ellos
que son los protagonistas de los goles
en el banco de los suplentes es decir
que pasó muchísimas cosas Uruguay
termina cayendo eliminada prácticamente
por su propia incapacidad Más allá de lo
que pasó luego del partido de la
molestia de cavani las protestas al
árbitro esas jugadas sobre cavani que
que en principio parecía penal y que no
fue pitada el penal a Darwin Núñez
muchas cosas pero creo que Uruguay queda
fuera por su propia incapacidad y
hablando de Uruguay y de su técnico
Diego Alonso tenemos que decir que
asumió en medio de una crisis y comenzó
su transitar este mismo año para lo que
fue la recta final de las eliminatorias
sudamericanas en cuatro partidos dentro
de las eliminatorias estuvo perfecto y
llegó a Uruguay del Séptimo puesto a la
clasificación es decir al tercer puesto
también ya en total en 12 presentaciones
con dirigiendo la Celeste ha ganado ocho
partidos tiene dos empates y dos
derrotas pero en Uruguay había mucha
expectativa por ver a Esta generación
avanzar hasta puestos de importancia en
el presente torneo pero veamos cómo se
sintió esta no clasificación con la voz
del periodista invitado de esa nación
Nicolás González blanco periodista del
canal ptv
Hola Luis el saludo para todos un gusto
estar aquí desde Montevideo con el
análisis de lo que ha sido esta dolorosa
eliminación de Uruguay en la Copa del
Mundo de Qatar 2022 un día difícil para
todos los uruguayos un partido en donde
Uruguay sí mostró lo que tal vez muchos
esperábamos funcionamiento juego
colectivo llegadas ser protagonista del
partido creo que con los cambios que
propuso Alonso fundamentalmente de la
mitad de la cancha hacia adelante
Uruguay hoy fue el gran protagonista
termina ganando bien el partido pero
queda corto en el resultado final porque
ese gol de Corea que dio vuelta el
resultado contra Portugal lo termina
eliminando Cómo se puede asimilar la
eliminación uruguaya Bueno tal vez
haciendo un balance de los tres partidos
y en ese balance uno puede encontrar
errores en la conformación del plantel
en los dos partidos iniciales y un juego
del cual se esperaba de Uruguay más
teniendo en cuenta como habían sido los
últimos cuatro partidos de la
eliminatoria en donde uruguayo ha estado
obligado a ganar sus partidos con un
juego bueno por parte del planteamiento
de Alonso y también de lo que plasmaron
los jugadores en la bueno eso no se vio
contra Corea y tampoco se vio contra
Portugal Uruguay estuvo en el debe tanto
en el funcionamiento como en el
planteamiento del juego en el partido
inicial con Corea donde termina
empatando 0 a 0 Y también en el segundo
partido contra Portugal donde termina
perdiendo 2 a 0 Más allá del
reconocimiento después unas horas
después de la FIFA de que ese segundo
penal había estado Maldonado la realidad
es que ese segundo penal hoy pesa porque
la diferencia de gol por más goles a
favor en este caso de Corea sobre
Uruguay lo termina dejando eliminado Esa
es la forma en la cual uno puede
asimilar esta derrota tal vez con
errores en la conformación del plantel
con errores del juego colectivo e
individual del equipo en donde
Seguramente se esperaba más en lo
individual de jugadores como Darwin
Núñez de jugadores como Federico
Valverde que tal vez no terminaron de
rendir lo que se esperaba buena figura
Rodrigo Betancourt que hoy
Lamentablemente se fue lesionado un buen
partido hoy de Luis Suárez un muy buen
partido de rascaeta del cual Seguramente
se sigue sin entender porque no jugó en
los partidos anteriores desde el vamos
con respecto a qué va a pasar ahora con
el Diego Alonso y con los jugadores
jóvenes que tienen la selección ese
proyecto a futuro Bueno lo primero que
hay que decir es que el contrato de
Alonso venció venció en este último
partido del mundial vencían el último
partido del mundial Uruguay hoy queda
eliminado y el contrato termina habrá
que ver qué pasa había ya versiones
anteriores que decían que seguramente
Alonso no iba a seguir para la
eliminatoria que va a comenzar en marzo
del próximo año habrá que esperar
respecto a cómo se tiene que plantear
Uruguay de a quién más Bueno sí hoy
termina una generación Luis Suárez
Edison cavani Diego godín Martín Cáceres
son jugadores que seguramente no van a
volver a tener minutos con la camiseta
de la selección uruguaya y hay una nueva
generación que comienza a instalarse
Federico Valverde Rodrigo Betancourt
Facundo Torres Brian Ocampo Darwin Núñez
Agustín Álvarez Martínez chiquilines
queda poco se van a ir llegando a esta
selección uruguaya para ser seguramente
protagonistas de la eliminatoria para el
Mundial del 2026 en Cana en Estados
Unidos y en México por aquí entonces los
dejo el saludo desde Uruguay y hoy
Uruguay ha quedado eliminado y hoy es un
gran dolor para todo el fútbol de
nuestro país
una lamentable noticia para el fútbol no
solo uruguayo sino tele continente
americano pero en otro Duelo ya hablando
del grupo G el que cerró esta fase de
grupos Camerún derrotó a Brasil Un gol
por cero Vincent a bubacar en el
agregado de este compromiso anotó tras
un contragolpe camerunés Juan Qué
sensación nos deja Y qué se puede decir
de titeque descanso a varios de sus
jugadores pensando ya en el partido de
la segunda ronda frente a Corea del Sur
Comenzando por Brasil destacar que para
este partido solamente jugaron como
titulares dos jugadores que ya hayan
sido iniciales en esta copa mundo fueron
Fred y Eder militao el resto era un
equipo completamente nuevo de ellos
destacar a fabinho que yo creo que sin
es un suplente de lujo esta no muy buen
nivel destacar lo que hicieron Anthony y
martinelli en el ataque destacar porque
no el buen partido de danielves y a sus
39 años no tuvo problemas en este
encuentro jugando por la banda derecha
obviamente ya no siendo esa motocicleta
que subía y bajaba por la banda eso para
destacar por parte hablando en de manera
individual de los jugadores de Brasil
cuando hablamos del colectivo ya es otro
plano se nota que es un equipo
completamente nuevo que no tiene el
engranaje que tiene el 11 titular de
este equipo de Brasil se notó sobre todo
cuando Camerún atacaba Cameron cuando
atacaba lo hacía con muchísimo peligro
tuvieron varias opciones tanto en la
primera parte como en la segunda parte y
al final el premio ese gol para África
un gol histórico porque nunca antes una
selección africana le había ganado a
Brasil en un mundial Brasil en siete
encuentros se le había ganado esos siete
partidos a las elecciones africanas en
la copa mundo el primero llegó para
vincenna bobocar un jugador que hizo un
despliegue físico enorme hasta hace un
tiempo se lo acusaba de estar gordo y
demostró que está más en forma que nunca
lo vimos correr por todo el campo a él
le sacaron una amarilla por bloquear una
jugada un ataque clarísimo que si no me
equivoco fue de rafinha y luego cuando
marque al gol es donde recibe la otra
amarilla es un reflejo de lo que ha sido
este jugador en este encuentro en
defensa y en ataque cabezazo precioso
para poner ese 1 a 0 definitivo para
Camerún contra Brasil en este partido
premio para premio para bajar que
también marcó contra Serbia y que se va
con un buen sabor de boca el mal sabor
de boca es el que eso no le alcanzó para
Cameron para avanzar a octavos de final
y si yo es llamarle la atención un poco
me imagino a boba porque hacer ese gol
quitarse la camiseta es expulsado cuando
todavía quizás Podrían haber soñado con
Por qué no en los segundos se quedaban
del partido con marcar otro gol queda un
poco para el reproche de este jugador
que termina siendo un gol histórico para
Camerún bueno bien lo decía Juan en
nuestro compañero Andrés doncel falta de
concentración por parte del jugador en
un partido tan importante pero Octavio
se habla mucho de la profundidad de
Brasil de ese equipo que mete miedo pero
hoy quizás no se reflejó en el terreno
esa profundidad Que tanto se habla en el
papel sí o no se reflejó o los
brasileros en verdad pensaron que les
iba a digamos a costar muy poco ganar
ese partido yo creo que en algún momento
del Duelo los brasileros pensaran
pensaron que con muy poco sacrificio y
van a ser su prevejas Camerún Y es que
en el papel en realidad Brasil con el
equipo que puso todavía era muchísimo
mejor al de al de Camerún inten fue
contra el arco rival no se le dieron las
cosas uno ve el resultado y uno podría
decir si no vio el partido que que
Camerún lo ganó bien y lo ganó con
intención y al final Cameron no lo
dominó lo dominó Brasil Brasil impuso su
juego evidentemente pero no llegó el gol
brasilero y aprovechó como bien nos
contaba Juana bugacar que al final fue
el mejor jugador de Camerún en el
mundial cada vez que entró cambio y y
marcó diferencia y fue él el que le dio
la victoria histórica al equipo al
equipo africano de todas maneras Claro
ese gol de Camerún Y si hubieses pasado
un gol de Suiza en su momento en ese
mismo momento Brasil quedaba segunda de
su grupo e iba a tener que jugar frente
a Portugal situación que evidentemente
no no estaba en los planes de nadie pero
Brasil pensaba que con ese equipo le iba
a estar para ganarle a Camerún y estar
tranquilos Hoy después del resultado
Brasil puede descansar puede tener
esperanzas en función a un mejor plantel
ahora en octavos de final seguramente
tendrá Neymar en cancha que ya empieza a
entrenar y a verse mejores condiciones
es una apuesta que esperemos verla en
los próximos días pero en Brasil siempre
se espera que la seleccione gane no se
espera otro resultado distinto y para
saber cómo vivieron este partido frente
a Camerún en tierras brasileñas vamos
con el siguiente reporte de nuestra
corresponsal permanente en Río de
Janeiro Valencia sacone
estar en los octavos de final hay que
decir que cada vez que juega las
canariña el país se paraliza no importa
si son empleados de un supermercado
funcionario Público de un gimnasio todo
el mundo para para ver el partido y la
palabra mágica es hexa el sexto
campeonato que Brasil quiere ganar hace
20 años que no consigue un título y la
presión sobre ti del entrenador es
altísima Especialmente con la incógnita
de Neymar todavía lesionado no se sabe
cuándo va a volver Eso sí el ambiente ha
vuelto a ser de alegría las calles
pintadas lo veis a mi espalda Brasil
sigue con mucha alegría y con mucha
esperanza y vamos a ver qué acontece en
los próximos juegos
Juan sabemos que hay mucha expectativa
en torno a Brasil pero qué nos puedes
aportar desde
Qatar sobre este combinado brasileño
la federación brasileña de fútbol acaba
de emitir un primer parte médico sobre
lo que pasó con Alex Téllez el lateral
del Sevilla tiene una contusión en la
rodilla derecha y le van a hacer
exámenes médicos esto preocupa porque
recordemos que ya Ahora tiene otro
lateral izquierdo a alexandro lesionado
tienen también a Danilo lesionado
preocupa mucho esta situación porque
vivimos a Brasil y terminó jugando con
marquiños de lateral izquierdo A este
paso casi que Dani Alves va a ser el
titular por la derecha para los octavos
de final
noticia que preocupa dentro de él
combinado brasileño pero por este mismo
grupo la selección de Suiza consiguió un
triunfo de tres goles por dos ante la
selección de Serbia en este partido
había mucho en el juego pero Octavio qué
análisis nos puede arrojar Este triunfo
de Suiza sobre Serbia tomando en cuenta
los resultados que han venido acumulando
desde el 2018 pasando por la Eurocopa
que se celebró el año pasado sí como
como bien lo explicabas Luis había mucho
en juego por por el Moro o por la
situación que hay entre estos dos países
por la rivalidad y Porque además lo que
lo que se jugaban evidentemente porque
el triunfo de server hubiese permitido
al equipo
clasificarse el hecho de que Suiza
tuviese que buscar el partido luego del
2 a 1 que lo tenía que lo encontraba
digamos con el resultado en contra y con
la posibilidad de quedarse afuera hizo
que Suiza fuese adelante fuese arriba a
buscar al resultado al final me parece
que lo termina ganando el que más lo
buscó el que el que tuvo la la intención
de ganar el partido el que no le pesó el
nervio ni el que ni el que digamos tuvo
las posibilidades de quedarse pensando
simplemente en eso en el temor de quedar
eliminado Suiza lo hizo nuevamente
mostró que es el mejor equipo del grupo
luego de Brasil
mostró que además Más allá de los
nombres importantes que tiene la
selección de Serbia Suiza es mucho más
equipo y eso al final termina pasando
factura en este tipo de torneos cuando
tú puedes conseguir que tus
individualidades rindan Pero además en
conjunto puedas doblegar a un equipo que
evidentemente en nombres tenía más peso
eso eso tiene un mérito un mérito enorme
y ahora Suiza tendrá la posibilidad de
de jugarse un lugar en los cuartos de
final evidentemente yo creo que está un
escalón por debajo de los equipos que
van a jugar esta ronda Pero quien dice
que Suiza pueda seguir peleando y
manteniéndose ahí entre los mejores de
esta Copa del Bueno ya hay un
antecedente que se veía en el euro un
suiza que venía disminuido respecto al
resto de los equipos que avanzaron y
logró meterse hasta los cuartos de final
pero vamos a catar con Natalia Ruiz
Natalia estuviste en este partido qué
detalles podemos obtener del mismo
sabemos que un partido que tenía una
ciertas connotaciones extra deportivas
que se estaban viviendo en el mismo
Así es pues se sabía que siempre cuando
se enfrentan estos dos equipos puede
haber ese ese otro telón de fondo no de
esas tensiones Y de cierta forma si
salieron a relucir en este partido sobre
todo ya sobre el final del encuentro
cuando Serbia Estaba desesperada por
lograr empatar el partido por lograr
ganar con sobre todo Shaka por parte de
Suiza que siempre Digamos como que le
pone Candela
al fuego y y de hecho incluso pues fue
el Arquero quien tuvo en algún momento
que venir a separar a Shaka
y jugadores suizos entre jugadores
serbios bueno además de esto también
hubo bastante
digamos tensión en las gradas con la
seguridad una vez más muy pendiente de
lo que sucedía o incluso un aviso en el
estadio pidiendo que no hubiera ningún
tipo de canto ni tampoco de grito que
fuera de alguna manera ofensivo
recordando un poco también lo que se
había pedido por ejemplo durante el
partido entre y Estados Unidos así que
mucha atención también con lo que
sucedía allí con los gritos que había de
algunos aficionados y finalmente Pues
creo que como Octavio lo lo contó Muy
bien pues fue un partido finalmente en
el que Suiza tuvo supo mantener este
este marcador supo ganar supo hacer
frente a las ofensivas de de un equipo
serbio que la gran mayoría pues juega en
la serie a en Italia y pues finalmente
Este es un excelente resultado se
esperaba también un equipo un partido
bastante apretado algunos problemas
también por parte del del banquillo
Entonces hubo todos estos elementos que
le dieron como ese esa esa gran tensión
Tal vez es el primer partido en donde
vemos un poco los jugadores
descontrolados pero Bueno finalmente es
Suiza la que logra la pase con muchísima
paciencia y con muy buen fútbol por
parte de Shaka que fue nombrado el mejor
jugador de este partido Aunque Bueno A
mi manera de ver Es sobre todo Shakira
quien hizo un excelente partido y quien
estuvo también en el origen de al menos
dos de los a tres goles de Suiza gracias
a Natalia de esta manera queda definido
todo el cruce en los octavos de final
unos cruces que comenzarán este día
sábado con el enfrentamiento entre
Países Bajos y la representación de
Estados Unidos luego estará Argentina
midiéndose a Australia Francia se estará
enfrentando a Polonia duelo de europeos
Inglaterra hará lo propio contra senegal
Japón sevira a Croacia el tiempo que
Brasil se enfrentará a Corea del Sur
Marruecos enfrentará a España y Portugal
a Suiza
Natalia Dentro de este grupo de llaves
Qué partido le parece más atractivo
Pues creo que cruces muy interesantes
Incluso el que comienza esta fase ya de
octavos que es entre Países Bajos y
Estados Unidos para saber si Estados
Unidos pues logra mantener ese nivel que
ha venido mostrando en estos tres
últimos partidos pero creo que uno que
puede ser muy interesante con muchísimas
emociones Y de pronto con con mucho
sobresaltos puede ser el partido entre
España y Marruecos Marruecos que viene
haciéndose un camino Muy bonito en este
mundial creando Una gran sorpresa y
sobre todo pues mostrando el fútbol
africano quizás en en su mejor esplendor
así que me iría por ese por ese cruce
que ya vendrá dentro de unos días entre
esas dos elecciones más teniendo en
cuenta lo que sucedió con España el día
de ayer de como Japón Pues los puso
patas arriba después de que venían tan
confiados no esa selección de Luis
Enrique Luis Enrique Incluso el que le
preguntan al final de ese partido usted
supo que durante tres minutos España
estaba por fuera del mundial y dijo No
ni siquiera me había dado cuenta me
hubiera dado un paro cardíaco así que
creo que es interesante un poco para ver
como España reacciona también después de
ese susto que se que se llevó así no se
hayan dado cuenta porque partía como una
gran favorita pero ayer se demostró que
ella este equipo Pues bien puede caer
ahora aprovecho para consultarle a Juan
Juan sabemos que tienes un corazón por
allí pero qué partido te parece
atractivo
definitivamente se encuentra entre
España Marruecos es atractivo Más allá
de por lo cultural y lo político que
tantos nexos que comparten estos dos
países Porque son dos equipos ofensivos
los equipos que van a disputar la pelota
atacar Así que seguramente que será un
buen intercambio de fútbol también muy
interesante ese Francia Polonia para mí
uno de los mejores ataques del mundial
contra una de las mejores defensas de
esta copa mundo el seleccionador
que en los días previos a este
enfrentamiento ya ha estado entrenando
los penaltis Muchísimas gracias Juan
Natalia por sus intervenciones Octavio
Quisiera saber además de cuál es tu
partido o cuál te parece Más atractivo
en estos octavos de final brevemente
hablar un poco de las críticas que hay
Respecto a los tiempos de recuperación
Argentina jugó su partido tiene que
jugar el día de mañana viene de jugar el
día martes y Brasil hará lo propio con
Corea en unos pocos días Sí yo yo creo
que como dice Juan y Natalia el España
Marruecos tiene una una tendencia
diferente por lo que significa para para
ambos países el hecho de cruzarse pero
yo quiero ver a los Estados Unidos
mañana sábado a ver si pueden dar ese
paso frente a un rival como Países Bajos
Quiero ver Argentina terminar de de
pasar y de considerarse favorita y
quiero volver a ver a Japón ahora frente
a un rival diferente como como Croacia y
el tema de los tiempos me parece Luis
que que tuvo que haberse hablado en el
sorteo o antes o en el momento en el que
se supiera en realidad y me parece que
durante el Mundial quejarse de eso ya no
tiene sentido cuando todos sabían que
eso iba a suceder pero evidentemente por
lo atípico del mundial por los días en
que se tiene que jugar y por la cantidad
es poco espacio libre no hay mucho más
que hacer en un mundial que se tiene que
terminar prácticamente muy rápido ya
tendremos oportunidad para analizar todo
lo que ocurrió en esta Copa del Mundo de
esta manera nosotros le ponemos punto
final a la presente edición de Diario
del mundial te agradecemos Octavio
también a nuestros compañeros en Qatar
Juan pupiales y Natalia Ruiz ustedes
sigan con más de la programación de
France 24 y también France 24.com
[Música]